thank you all for coming i merit jano
director of the Finance and Economic
Policy concentration and a professor
here at sepa and the law school and it's
my great privilege to introduce and
welcome David Miller to speak with us
today as you know mr. Miller is the
chief investment officer of the troubled
asset relief program tarp a position
that he's held since 2009 he comes to
this very important assignment with a
long history in finance having worked as
a portfolio manager at a firm in Texas
and having worked at Goldman Sachs for
perhaps nine years ago nine years or so
and with an undergraduate degree in
economics leavened with training also in
film I say and also of course an MBA
with distinction from Harvard so we're
very honored that he is taking time to
be with us to share his perspectives on
how this program has operated and
perhaps some overall perspectives as
well so please join me in welcoming him
with us today
I failed to mention you have little
cards on your seat we will be inviting
you to please if you have write those on
the card I think we have some press with
us today welcome if you are a press
member and you have a question please
indicate that on the card and we'll try
and cluster the questions during the Q&A
pass them to the side and someone will
pick them up and bring them up to me and
then we'll make sure to cover all the
issues raised so thank you very much
good afternoon Thank You professor G now
for the kind introduction see if I can
balance this and this I am a recovering
banker so we always need a PowerPoint I
am honored to be here today at sepa
which has been addressing international
problems in the public and private
spheres for over half a century as the
chief investment officer of tarp which
is one of the most unpopular programs in
government history wasn't entirely sure
how many people would show up in fact
early in the program a congressman said
to me said David my constituents heat
your program they rank its popularity
somewhere between the Taliban and the
swine flu so again thank you all for
being here today I firmly believe that a
robust financial system is crucial to a
well functioning economy is one
important component of the extraordinary
economic progress that's been made in
the world over the past few centuries
history is demonstrated that the
financial system overall not every piece
of it but overall is a force for good
even if it goes off track from time to
time if you don't believe that our
society needs a robust financial system
then you will probably disagree with
everything the United States government
did over the past two years and
everything I'm about to say the
financial system consists of
institutions and capital flows capital
is like oxygen to the economy most
people generally don't think about
oxygen
unless they're not getting enough of it
and by then they have a serious problem
similarly if capital is not flowing
freely the economy will begin to spiral
downward the purpose of the financial
system is to allocate capital credit and
equity efficiently to foster economic
growth this process allows savers who
want future income to direct capital to
those who wish to borrow or consumed in
the present it aims to establish prices
for all these types of risk the system
of capital flows is highly complex
interconnected and global as we have
experienced this system sometimes breaks
down today I will briefly discuss some
of the reasons for the most recent
breakdown and evaluate the success of
the US government's intervention in
financial markets I will approach this
topic with somewhat of a Treasury
centric bias given my role on tarp but
that should not minimize the collective
efforts of other agencies including the
FDIC and the Federal Reserve that took
substantial decisive and critical action
finally I'll discuss the implications of
these market interventions including
comprehensive regulatory reform and
future considerations for the global
economy see if I can get this to work
very good always need an executive
summary as well okay bye now the general
causes of the financial crisis are well
known and well documented the financial
crisis inquiry commission or the fcic
just released a 650 page plus report
which identifies sufficient blame for
the multitude of bad actors I encourage
all of you were interested in the causes
to review the report as well as other
significant academic contributions
written over the past few years
including many by Columbia professors
but for the sake of brevity the
following are some of the more important
causes I'm not going to spend a lot of
time on that led up to the crisis in
2008 abundant and cheap capital combined
with weak lending standards we had over
leveraged consumers and over leveraged
financial institutions there were poorly
aligned incentives primarily for
compensation poor risk management by
banks they were information and risk
asymmetries in short it's customers
agents investors and other actors didn't
understand or completely ignore the risk
they were taking there were shortcomings
of the rating agency system
there was an explosion in the use of
derivatives and securitization products
which weren't properly monitored and in
general there was an inadequate
regulatory framework which was
fragmented ineffective and insufficient
there were also government policies and
entities that subsidized and encouraged
the over consumption of housing so all
of the above and some others helped
create and sustain a real estate bubble
which made its eventual collapse ever
more painful it's just a chart showing a
hundred years of real estate prices in
real terms most of you lived through
this but in case you missed it we had a
large real estate bubble beginning
really in the end of the late 90s and
through the decade which is still in the
process of correcting as Warren Buffett
famously said you only find out who was
swimming naked when the tide goes out
and so it was that when the tide went
out in 2008 many of the largest players
were very exposed so why does it matter
that some financial institutions acted
imprudently Ord become insolvent by
making bad decisions why not let them
fail the non financial institution is
insolvent that institution can
reorganize under bankruptcy protection
relatively smoothly the core business
weather is making drywall or
semiconductors can continue to operate
not so with financial institutions so
two important concepts worth mentioning
or insolvency and illiquidity simply put
insolvency occurs when a firm's
liabilities exceed its assets which is
the definition of a bankrupt entity lack
of liquidity means you don't have enough
cash to pay your obligations firm can be
insolvent but liquid where it can be
solvent but illiquid or both with a
financial institution the two are often
tied fear is about in institutions
solvency usually causes a liquidity
problem and this in turn can result in
potential insolvency if enough assets go
into forced liquidation at fire-sale
prices so to understand what occurred in
the fall of 08 and 09 and therefore
understand the response of the United
States government it is important to
highlight from the key structural
problems that allow bank runs to become
a system at crisis over the past few
decades financial institutions
increasingly complex and interconnected
so the largest firms became reliant an
on deposit short-term funding which
seemed stable but like a group of
pigeons in Central Park the funding
flatted the first signs of trouble some
banks had leverage ratios exceeding 30
to 1 meaning losses of four percent on
assets would render them insolvent many
had large complicated derivative books
including exposures to off-balance sheet
vehicles there was generally lack of
transparency as to what exposures and
risks these banks held the largest
institutions had significant
counterparty exposures that spanned
across borders thus when the housing
bubble burst the fear of holding claims
against weaker institutions resulted in
counterparties withdrawing short-term
funding and other forms of lending and
thereby beginning a vicious negative
feedback loop so if the underlying
problem and exposure of an institution
were truly idiosyncratic and unique to
that institution then clearly that
institution could and should be allowed
to fail and the chances of a systemic
crisis would be low however when most or
all of the financial institutions have
the same exposures the problem becomes
systemic in nature so just touching
briefly to recap in time how the
systemic run began and some of the major
players first in March 08 Bear Stearns
collapsed after a classic run on the
bank scenario followed by indymac in
July the government-sponsored
enterprises or gses Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac were put into
conservatorship that September Lehman
Brothers filed for bankruptcy which set
into motion the acute phase of the
crisis the reserve fund it's a large
money market fund if you recall suffered
losses and quote broke the buck causing
investors to begin withdrawing money
from short-term credit markets bank and
non-bank financial institutions such as
Wachovia Merrill and AIG began rapidly
declining as credit spreads blew out and
collateral was called on the losing
derivative positions interbank lending
ceased and this is exhibited in the
spike in the LIBOR oh I asked spread
which is a general measure that banks
charge each other over the Fed overnight
index rate this really indicated that
banks didn't know the hell
of other banks and is generally used to
show the stress in the system as you can
see typically the library is brad is 5
to 10 basis points on sep tember first
2008 went up to about 50 basis points
and by october of 2008 the spread
reached 3 338 and spiked even a little
bit higher the run in the financial
system at this point had begun
completely in earnest and I can tell you
it was quite a scary time banks could no
longer operate at this point without
government assistance and businesses
were unable to raise capital
foreclosures were increasing and home
prices were falling with downloaded
projections of as much as an additional
thirty percent so the credit freeze
ensued the likes of which had not been
seen since the Great Depression so
before we discussed the response it is
important to understand some context
over the past two years many
policymakers from both sides of the
political aisle as well as noted
economist and other authorities have
objected to the government's response to
the financial crisis do generally to an
unwavering support for free market
capitalism citing moral hazard such
critics of the government's actions have
asked why not let the banks fail so
quickly let's take a look fundamentally
the systemic bank failures would have
been catastrophic for this and other
countries economies with credit
contraction businesses would no longer
if funded new projects students would
like yourself would have been unable to
borrow for tuition and consumers would
have been unable to finance large
purchases like cars or homes an
individual and a businesses access to
bank accounts even those insured by the
fdic would have been materially
disrupted as institutions and mass would
have gone into receivership and
resolution fear causes bank runs even
for institutions that might be
fundamentally sound with the economic
engine broken unemployment would have
materially spiked and GDP would have
dipped accordingly this drop in economic
activity in the US which is still the
world's largest economy could have
sparked the global depression so I
firmly believe that there was no better
alter
than to intervene to save the system and
to debate moral hazard and reform once
the system have been stabilized
historians economists politicians
members of the media and the American
public will review the merits of our
response as we're doing today be done in
graduate school classrooms media outlets
textbooks and academic journals such a
debate who ideally be undertaken under
the umbrella of a stable financial
system so while tarp has garnered much
of the headlines and frankly much of the
criticism I submit that the government's
response was actually reasonably well
orchestrated across independent agencies
including the Federal Reserve FDIC and
Treasury tarp was one pungent ingredient
in the government's alphabet soup for
those of you who have served in the
federal government you understand the
coordinating any intergovernmental
effort is no small feat during the first
stage of the response the federal
government injected a significant amount
of liquidity into the financial system
an essential role of a central bank is
to provide liquidity as the lender of
last resort to maintain a liquid and
functioning banking system the Federal
Reserve fulfilled its mission through a
series of well-designed programs with a
bevy of acronyms too long to list here
these tools provided short-term
liquidity of financial institutions and
directly to borrowers and credit market
investors I don't have time to go
through those today but I really can't
emphasize enough how important the
actions of the Federal Reserve were in
addressing that liquidity crisis the
FDIC has also been a significant partner
through the financial crisis two of the
agency's critical actions we're creating
the temporary liquidity guarantee
program also known as T lgp which
provide access to credit markets for
viable institutions and the other was
raising insurance coverage on bank
deposits from 100 to 250 thousand which
is an effort to restore confidence prior
to the creation of tarp is also worth
mentioning the Treasury took other
decisive action in the early part of the
crisis Treasury supported the GSEs and
guaranteed money market mutual
both were critical actions and
maintaining stability in housing finance
and short-term funding markets most
Americans believe that their money
market accounts with check writing
capabilities were essentially bank
accounts that were FDIC insured
full-blown run on this multi-trillion
dollar industry would have been
absolutely catastrophic and yet despite
these actions the tools available to the
federal government were inadequate
credit markets and interbank lending
remain frozen institutions really didn't
trust one another so transacting ceased
concerns about solvency make individual
firms act rationally and in their own
self-interest but to the detriment of
the financial system so more needed to
be done but at this point the federal
government had essentially emptied its
toolkit and it's important point to note
that the federal government has enormous
authorities those powers are expressly
granted by Congress so in order to
expand the federal government's toolkit
an act of Congress was literally
required so the emergency economic
stabilization act 2008 or ISA passed
Congress and was signed into law by
president bush in October of 2008 the
dual mandate of financial stability and
taxpayer protection ISA authorized the
Secretary of the Treasury to purchase
troubled assets in financial
institutions and make guarantees of
certain assets with 700 billion over two
year investment horizon ISA transactions
would be voluntary not calling the
nationalization of banks the legislation
provided the necessary flexibility to
design programs targeted at the various
market dislocations we quickly went to
work deploying the capital with limited
resources infrastructure and staffing
while tarp is now a 200 plus mature
organization with many functions and
robust systems I can tell you that the
government startup look very different
in those early days so before I discuss
the tarp strategy and evaluated success
is worth making a few comments on the
extraordinary challenges that we faced
in an era where the term unprecedented
is used all too often I can tell you
that there really was no blue
for decision-making other than using
sound judgment and relying on what my
predecessor coined the two beacons
whereby each action to have to balance
financial stability and taxpayer
protection and you have to chart the
right course in between those two we're
often faced with making difficult
decisions from a set of bad choices and
had to pick the least bad option under
difficult time pressure and incomplete
information the initial strategy focused
on Treasury making direct purchases as
you recall but given the increasing
speed and severity of the crisis
implementing this original plan would
have been too slow too small and likely
ineffective situation was extremely
dynamic and required constant
reassessment rather than dogmatically
stick the initial plan Treasury adapted
its strategy accordingly seems simple
enough the tarp strategy be simplified
three components one recapitalized the
banking system to revive the credit
markets and three increase confidence
through transparency to bring back in
private capital it is important at this
point to mention that there were other
important aspects of the government's
recovery plan notably the American
Recovery Reinvestment Act also known as
era where the stimulus and there were
other several other home preservation
initiatives both are important but way
beyond the scope of this presentation
today we have far too little time so in
formulating an effective tarp strategy
an important balance needed to be struck
it was often huge disagreement about the
best course of action that was the
do-nothing camp let the markets work it
out and as I discussed that was neither
viable nor responsible the opposite camp
supported the complete nationalization
of banks and that was also neither
practical nor desirable I also want to
note that the federal government's
action having been there were taken to
reduce the pain inflicted on what is
commonly called Main Street was it to
save particular institutions or
executives and not because of politics
or ideology but to avoid a far worse
economic
for the American people is always
difficult to prove the counterfactual
but in the absence of tarp the economic
environment would have been far worse
there was a way of stabilizing the
system without quote bailing out the
banks then surely this would have been
the preferred option so Treasury settled
upon a series of initiatives aimed at
stopping the downward spiral and
allowing the financial institutions the
necessary breathing room to recover the
first set of programs had the goal of
recapitalising the banking system so
that it can continue to function first
program was the capital purchase program
cpp and the target investment program to
purchase preferred equity which would
qualify as tier 1 capital enviable
financial institutions such investments
included 165 billion in eight of the
largest financial institutions and an
additional 80 billion in another 700
banks Treasury further committed to
guarantee certain assets of Bank of
America and Citigroup under the asset
guarantee program Treasury also invested
40 billion in AIG which also got
additional funds from the federal
reserve so these initial capital
injections were done in a way to
maximize the stability of the system
many have called for more onerous terms
or outright nationalization let me
briefly explain why that wouldn't have
been optimal first to maximize
participation in the plan to
recapitalize the banking system terms
have to be reasonable and consistent to
all eligible institutions be at large or
small public or private second for those
institutions that receive exceptional
assistance it's taking one hundred
percent ownership or impairing creditors
might have been destabilizing why you
ask because if markets suspected that
the next week is bank would be
nationalized it would have no ability to
fund itself or raise additional private
equity credit spreads for that
institution would blow out equity prices
would plummet which were essentially the
opposite goals of our program this cycle
would have then continued to the next
week as bank so i believe the decision
to inject preferred equity
in almost all cases was balanced and
targeted approach to maximizing
stability while ultimately providing an
opportunity for Treasury to recoup its
funds going to the second part of the
tarp strategy which we can come back to
more later was to help restore credit
markets Treasury launched two large
programs which were aimed at restarting
credit markets through the
securitization markets the two were
called the term asset backed securities
loan facility or health and the
public-private investment program known
as peep it as you'll see the theme here
is we like acronyms at the Treasury
Department talth aimed at restarting the
ABS or asset backed securities Asian
markets that provide credit to consumers
and small businesses p pip was launched
to restart the frozen market for legacy
mortgage-backed securities and
essentially help price discovery in a
market that was essentially frozen and
had been for a while both of these
programs brought in private capital
expertise and help resuscitate the
securitization markets which are an
important source of credit albeit a
smaller part of credit going forward the
final part of the strategy was to ease
this to ease the systemic crisis was to
increase transparency this came in the
form of the Supervisory capital
assessment program the SCAP which is
commonly known as the stress tests the
goal of this program was to promote
confidence in the markets by providing a
greater give greater degree of
transparency and institutional
accountability the financial system
needed to be recapitalized by private
investors but private capital couldn't
be raised until the conditions of the
major financial institutions were known
Treasury worked alongside federal
regulators to develop a comprehensive
forward-looking stress test for the 19
largest bank holding companies to
determine which ones would need more
capital if economic conditions
deteriorated significantly more than
expected these tests force banks to
disclose significant amounts of data
related to the risks of the market so
that private investors could assess
their health and assess each institution
individually
the stress tests were essential and
restoring market confidence and allowing
private capital to come back in banks
raised about 150 billion dollars in
private capital initially which
ultimately saved hundreds of billions of
taxpayer dollars to help restore market
confidence reopen credit markets and
laid the groundwork for economic growth
here's a list of the commitments made to
date totaling 475 billion be happy to go
through any individual program in the
Q&A in more detail as you can see we
there quite a number of them and each
has its own story in history of the 475
410 billion has been dispersed in
investments we've received back
approximately 275 billion to date and
remain committed to winding down the
portfolio prudently so that the
government no longer holds investments
in the private sector and while much
work remains and there is considerable
amount of market risk to these
investments we anticipated the cost of
the program overall will be negligible
and merely a fraction of what was
initially estimated again it's my view
that again subject to market conditions
the investment portfolio when taken as a
whole will likely break even so
framework for evaluating tarp in any
assessment of the response to the crisis
there are several important measures
I'll offer up 31 has financial stability
been restored so that the financial
system is able to support rather than
impede economic growth to how quickly
has the government been able to return
the financial system to private cap
hands and three what was the cost so
first here are a few metrics that we
look at there are many more but only fit
two on one slide interbank lending rates
LIBOR OS spread that we discussed
earlier relatively quickly came down to
normalise levels over all the credit
default swaps of financial institutions
shown below normalized didn't come
obviously way back down to 2006 2000
given a lot of volatility in the markets
but certainly came back to more
normalized levels there many other
credit spreads that we look at but by
really all accounts by the early of
middle of 2009 borrowing rates had come
down significantly particularly for
businesses individuals and even state
and local governments companies began to
access the capital markets again bond
market rates fell substantially and
30-year mortgage rates reached historic
lows also important to note that
Americans net worth had rebounded
substantially starting in 2009 and tarp
has also helped create the conditions
necessary for economic growth and it's
important to note that i'm saying
conditions necessary because tarp by
itself was not meant to start creating
economic growth merely helped create the
conditions despite that real GDP is
risen for five straight quarters private
sector firms are slowly beginning the
higher began and the housing market
which is still a drag on the economy has
shown some signs of stabilizing
economist Mark Zandi and Alan Blinder
concluded that without tarp the stimulus
and other government actions gdp would
still have been contracting in 2010 and
around four percent unemployment could
have reached 16 and a half percent and
the US economy would now be experiencing
deflation and to be sure there is much
more to be done in order to heal the
economy tarp helped put us on the right
path the second measure of success speed
of exiting the return of private capital
and we have been exiting investments far
faster than expected thanks of raise
substantial capital as I discussed
earlier and shown on the top chart there
which really shows the speed and extent
that that's happened the largest really
did so in early 2009 we've also been a
reluctant shareholder which the goal is
to minimize our involvement in
day-to-day companies most financial
institutions no longer have financial
support and I'll talk a little about
later about the exceptional assistance
firms the bottom chart here shows again
the you know tier 1 a risk weighted ask
that essentially capital ratios still
have some room to go but have rebounded
sharply and you can see the red
component
they're being the tarp has has become a
smaller component of the system-wide
tier 1 in cases where we did become
large equity holders Citigroup GM
Chrysler Ally Financial and AIG
significant restructuring restructurings
have taken place which have created
value for taxpayers and de-risked the
institutions in these cases we have
either exited our positions or begun the
process of exiting which should be
completed in the next two years third
measure of success is the cost easiest
to show the financial cost to taxpayers
as you can see will ultimately be
minimal tarps official cost estimates
from the CBO have declined from an
initial estimate of 356 down to 25
billion and that 25 billion essentially
will be the amount disbursed for housing
initiatives or at least the amount that
they estimate the housing initiatives
again outside of the scope of my
activity and are not investments where
the dollars are not expected to come
back given that tarps cost is now
estimated to be no more than the housing
initiatives I think we can take stock
there's obviously a lot of work to be
done and market conditions will change
the value of the investments that being
said bigger picture an IMF study found
that the average net fiscal cost of
resolving 40 banking crisis since 1970
was thirteen percent of GDP contrast the
current impact on the deficit from the
intergovernmental response including the
rescue of the GSEs which are not
included here is projected to be less
than one percent of GDP hopefully you'll
go down even further but comparatively
pretty good so let's talk a little bit
about lessons learned and some
shortcomings I think one of the key
lessons learned in the crisis that
decisive and overwhelming force is
required when faced with proportionally
overwhelming circumstances if you're
going to intervene then your
intervention must be of a size and scope
that it will literally move mark
it's such an approach will ultimately
result in fewer resources deployed much
lower cost to taxpayers and a far
quicker recovery there's no silver
bullet and government officials must be
willing to utilize their entire arsenal
including monetary fiscal and regulatory
authorities to achieve the desired
result so while I acknowledge the
successes of the program I think there
were a few shortcomings and program has
faced significant criticisms let me
touch on a few of them first is
communications communicating the
rationale for tarp leading up to and
after the passage of visa was incredibly
difficult the message really does matter
and I acknowledge that explaining the
program to the American people perceived
to be a Wall Street bailout was and has
been a steep uphill climb we hope that
the minimal cost and some of the other
benefits will help people understand the
necessity of the initiatives taken by
both the Bush and Obama teams that a
functioning Wall Street is fundamental
to a functioning Main Street
unfortunately in a resource-constrained
environment we had to spend much of our
time focused internally on getting the
programs designed and implemented and
devoted fewer hours to explaining these
essential yet exceedingly complex
actions secondly the strategic shift
from direct asset purchases to capital
injections while necessary allowed
critics to suggest that we were changing
the rules mid-game acting irresponsibly
or did not have a well-articulated plan
for the 700 billion whoever implementing
the original strategy as i said before
would have been too slow too small
ineffective and so the strategy was
adapted and despite criticisms we faced
and it may have put a temporary dent in
our credibility I think this decision
was courageous and necessary third
executive compensation was a thorny
issue throughout it still is Congress
mandated that certain restrictions on
executive comp which Treasury
implemented nonetheless the seemingly
endless litany of newspaper headlines
proclaiming I popping banker bonuses
enraged the public now we had a strike a
very delicate balance those firms
receiving government assistance should
prohibitive conditions but also needed
to compete in the marketplace and retain
top talent now while now much of the
Fuehrer has subsided I suspect this was
and will be a difficult issue going
forward like finally important pointers
moral hazard which has been debated
through tarps existence simply put well
institutions act badly in the future
because they have will expect another
rescue it's one of the most significant
undesired consequences of government
intervention and while this was
unavoidable regulatory reform which I'll
discuss very briefly later attempts to
address this issue so what does this all
mean what are the implications for the
future so I want to separate the impact
of the crisis into three broad
categories first is regulatory reform
second is implication for future crisis
and three the long-term impact on the
global economy so one of the serious
problems with large-scale intervention
is a mansion or bailouts people call it
is the impact on future decision-making
and risk-taking moral hazard is simply
unavoidable it would be entirely
unacceptable to simply return to the
same system with the same rules and same
bad incentives and expect that we
wouldn't end up in the same place going
forward in fact because the intervention
was so effective and markets recovered
so much more quickly than many expected
it's even more likely that we would
repeat the same mistakes leading up to
two thousand eight so a strong
regulatory response was required to
improve the system I think one of the
important legacies of the crisis is a
reversal and attitudes towards financial
regulation an adequate regulatory
framework should provide tools for
resolution that eliminates the need to
choose between doing nothing and keeping
a systemic institutional I've simply to
avoid crisis new regulation should
reduce or eliminate expectations of
future bailouts and thereby reduce moral
hazard I think an important point is
though despite that a proper balance
needs to be struck additional
regulations
should not stifle financial innovation
and efficient capital allocation to so
crucial to our strength and global
competitiveness such a system has
invented the money market mutual funds
credit cards interest rate swaps
low-cost index funds and exchange-traded
funds just to name a few good products
so the Wall Street the dodd-frank wall
street reform and consumer protection
act dodd-frank was initially proposed in
2009 and signed into law in July of 2010
the Act does represent the most sweeping
change to financial regulation since the
Great Depression this point many details
have been delegated to various
rulemaking authorities and are still
being determined so evaluating the
practical implications of this evolving
regulatory regime is quite premature but
just to quickly touch on the major
tenants here they are again it's very
complicated Act there are many pieces to
it these are just some of the key issues
don't have time to go in depth if
they're specific questions would be
happy to try and answer but again we've
got a systemic financial stability
Oversight Council the Act really
requires that regulators impose
substantially stronger prudential
standards which really will involve
stress testing living wills and higher
capital ratios the Act establishes a
framework for regulating the derivatives
market there's resolution authority as i
mentioned to break apart large
institutions and there's a Consumer
Financial Protection Agency again as I
said before there's a lot more to this
legislation and the implementation will
take a lot of time and a lot of debate
and discussion will go into it going
forward however when thinking about the
implications of a post-crisis world
clearly the change in the regulatory
landscape is one of the most important
but no matter how much we improve the
regulatory system we are always
responding to the last crisis the causes
of the next crisis are likely to be very
different let's not forget that there
been scores of financial crisis over the
past few centuries it really is folly to
believe that the next cry
can be completely avoided any more than
future recessions can be eliminated the
sheer speed with which a financial
system can collapse combined with
unforeseen events makes timely
pre-emptive government or regulatory
action challenging I think the answer is
that regular regulation must be nimble
must constantly adapt to changing
conditions that a regulation can succeed
in mitigating the severity of dynamics
that might cause a crisis any regulatory
regime must be prepared for unexpected
events or unanticipated consequences
must coordinate globally since we live
in a world of complex global capital
flows system must have flexibility to
respond unexpected in destabilizing
events regulators should not be faced
with having no option as we did in tarp
to keep banks alive I think dodd-frank
creates a framework for this the crisis
brought forward another host of issues
that were otherwise ignored or unmasked
in the lead-up to the crisis journalist
Martin Wolfe wrote that the crisis quote
catapulted us into the future and
besides regulatory reform they'll be
lasting changes to the US and global
economy there are a few so first the
crisis caused the beginning of a long
and painful process of reducing private
debt which had been growing
unsustainably for decades second the
financial crisis has exposed the issue
of unsustainable long-term gum
government deficits and liabilities in
Western economies including the United
States these issues will be heavily
debated going forward third Housing
Finance will be dramatically changed the
administration recently issued a report
to Congress on the future of the housing
finance market while a healthy debate
will ensue it is clear that the federal
government will have a reduced role in
housing finance in the future fourth the
global impact of the crisis has been
significant it unmasked serious
financial and other structural problems
facing the eurozone that many of its
member European leaders are working very
hard to address
and finally the crisis demonstrated the
importance of increased economic
cooperation to achieve a better balanced
global economy I think we've seen that
the role of emerging economies think g 7
verse now the g20 has really changed the
debate on the importance going forward
of the emerging economies in the
dialogue so let me make a few closing
remarks there's my conclusion financial
author James grant wrote in 1992 that
quote progress is cumulative in science
and engineering but cyclical and finance
and that remains true today
unfortunately and while there have been
scores of financial crises going back
centuries phenomenal economic progress
has been sustained which has improved
the lives of millions if not billions of
people globally despite the painful
setbacks along the way the causes of
this financial crisis built up over
decades and while the acute part of the
crisis is in the past we must remain
vigilant and strive for continuous
improvement of the system in short we
should not let memories fade and
attitudes towards robust oversight
diminish more on a personal note I want
to share with you my path to public
service I'd always believed that public
service is an honor and a privilege but
had always thought that I would do it
later in my career when the crisis began
I wrote a letter to Hank Paulson
volunteering to join the Treasury
Department wherever I could help out I
wanted to serve my country at a time and
in a capacity which I best could give in
my professional background and it has
been truly a life-changing experience
I've been privileged to serve alongside
colleagues at Treasury and from other
agencies who have worked tirelessly as a
team during a crucial time further I've
been gratified by the many talented and
dedicated professionals from both the
public and private sectors who
volunteered like me their expertise and
services during the crisis that the
taxpayer may break even on the tarp
program is really a testament to the
commitment of many individuals and
extraordinary leadership provided
notably by secretary Paulson and
secretary
inner policymaking is very challenging
and can be at times all-consuming it
involves making very difficult decisions
and balancing difficult trade-offs often
you must make choices from a set of bad
options with limited information you
don't get to test options in a
laboratory and you don't get do-overs
your decisions have far-reaching
ramifications that can be played out in
congressional hearings on the front
pages in op-ed columns and in classrooms
Cara sepa and in academic journals you
will need thick skin they say that if
you want a friend in Washington you
should get a dog you will be criticized
from the press Congress academia the
blogosphere not to mention the for
oversight bodies that tarp as the
intense scrutiny and criticism is
central to America's policy-making
process and does help ensure the utmost
accountability and transparency because
the stakes are so high because
government policies affect the daily
lives of so many Americans the work is
highly challenging and consequential so
it is my hope that once the political
dust settles economist bankers
policymakers historians maybe the
American people will conclude that tarp
was one crucial to highly effective in
executing its mission and three
unprecedented in its transparency so in
closing want to reiterate the tarp was
never meant to be an economic panacea
our economy still chases faces many
challenges high unemployment fiscal
imbalances but I think tarp played a
necessary role in restoring financial
stability which allowed policymakers the
ability to focus on the recovery I hope
that tarp teaches us to be vigilant in
identifying and proactively meeting
future challenges in the financial
system these challenges will look very
different than the recent storm and
facing them will not be easy so I
applaud your decision to attend seba to
wrestle with the mounting global
challenges and for the many different
and consequential career paths you will
take in the future i encourage you to
leave with your passions i hope that
many of you will heed the call to serve
your country at some point during your
careers our country's future depends
upon talented individuals making
significant contributions through public
service is only through the efforts of
dedicated individuals the positive
change can be accomplished so thank you
for the opportunity to share my
perspective of you today and be happy to
take any questions framework is reduced
I think that's a great question i mean i
think as you as you said the goal of
dodd-frank was to make sure that there
would never be a need for tarp going
forward i think specifically capital
injections to keep institutions alive
wouldn't be necessary and particularly
because there's now resolution authority
that being said I think a lot was
learned through this process I think
particularly from the Fed in terms of
liquidity programs you know again
hopefully those don't have to be used
but if they're used prudently I think
there was a lot to learn there about
bringing in private capital and
expertise and essentially creating
programs that phase themselves out over
time again a central bank if they're
going to lend in a crisis you want to
design the program so that they are
relatively more expensive than normal
times but cheaper than the stress times
and I think if you can design a program
and we saw this for instance in the
towel fair when there was absolutely no
market for asset backed securities and
prices were fifteen to twenty percent
yields for things that used to be you
know essentially 50 basis points over
libor designing a program that was
extremely attractive at the beginning
compressing the spreads down to a point
where actually borrowers didn't want to
use the Fed because they were more
expensive than the alternative so I
think some of those issues were
certainly things that can be learned
again and then finally the people i
think treasury will need to expand
significantly given a lot of the
initiatives under dodd-frank being able
to utilize some of the investment and
legal talent
that's come over to tarp when tarp lines
down in some of those areas be at
resolution or the Office of Financial
Research I think you'll be able to bring
the expertise but again the authority
granted under Issa to invest in your
programs has expired I suspect it will
take policymakers a very long time
before they're able to go near anything
sounding like tarp which as we know is
is a four-letter word okay thank you let
me read you some of the questions that i
can read some of this handwriting I'm
afraid I'm not sure I can I'm not sure
you're alone they're quite a few a
little hard to read but one question is
how have we really reduced the risk of
bailouts well I think it's a good
question i think first in the near term
with soggy near-term and longer-term i
think in the near term the the first
thing that's been focused on is is
capital capital and banks and i think
you've seen really a significant
increase in capital ratios and that
that's continuing regulators are very
focused institutions have gone out and
raise capital will continue to do it so
the ratios are not only before right
before the crisis but significantly
higher than then then well before the
crisis so I think that that's one and
that's an important again an important
part of the health of a bank longer-term
again it's going to depend on the
implementation of dodd-frank which
really is in its early stages so I think
better oversight is critical and there's
a lot of work to do having been part of
a start-up within the government
bureaucracy is very challenging things
that you I think from the outside expect
exist like massive infrastructure and
hundreds and hundreds of qualified
people just simply doesn't exist it
takes a long time to actually go out and
build these these important pieces of
oversight that will I think make the
system you know even more stable going
forward but but those are big challenges
and again I think time will tell how
effective give
given what's built up but it's it's I
think a little too early to tell but I
think looking at measures like various
credit metrics looking at capital both
here and globally and I think in some
ways we're ahead of some other countries
in perhaps other part parts of the
banking sector particularly smaller
banks are more challenged we can talk a
little more about that but I think so
the system is more stable but there's a
lot of work to do so that there isn't
another big destabilizing event thank
you here is a broad philosophical
question about the banking sector you
said that a healthy banking sector or
Wall Street is vital to the well-being
of the economy in the long term should
we and can we decouple the fortunes of
the nation and the risky parts of the
financial sector in other words can we
ensure the that the health of banks that
are in the business of lending while at
the same time paring down the influence
of parts of the banking sector do that
do not contribute to real wealth
creation or social purpose I think it's
I think it's an interesting question I
think d couple is difficult because
everything is so interconnected I think
they're also there are certain
activities that go on that I think are
just harder for people to see how it
touches their lives you know responsible
securitization for example isn't by
itself dangerous it just needs to be
done under you know better oversight and
better incentives etc but I think you
know that creates essentially funnels
credit to people in a different way than
your classic bank lending arrangement
but it doesn't make it fundamentally
wrong and you know as we saw when those
markets shut down that has a direct
impact people couldn't get an auto loan
and that's because a lot of auto loans
are done through securitisation markets
now they may be lower in importance
going forward and banks may pick up some
of the slack but again I think you can't
expect to go back to a 1950s banking
model so that's I think you know that's
that's one point I think another point
is that dodd-frank is going to reduce
some of the activities that some people
may see is not core two basic lending
and a lot of the details need to be
worked out
volcker rule being one example as
something that bank holding companies
banks that enjoy I think a lot of the
privileges that come with that be it
FDIC insurance or access to fed windows
those will no longer be doing certain
types of proprietary investing under
under the rules and the details are
getting worked out as I said so I think
there has been some progress made there
but again there are different types of
institutions in the system but we can't
pretend that they're not completely
interconnected so you can't just
separate them out and say 11 we can just
let you know sort of go down and and and
then everything else will be okay at
least we couldn't in 2008 but going
forward I think there are significant
changes thank you here is a question
from a person from the press the US
Treasury owns ninety-two percent of AIG
when do you plan to start selling your
steak and how confident are you of the
of the entire of recovering the entire
investment okay yes we do own ninety-two
percent of AIG as many of you know in a
restructuring that occurred over many
months but is now closed as a result of
that the Federal Reserve because a big
lender has been repaid and Treasury owns
just over 1.6 billion common shares
which is the ninety two percent there
are eight percent that trade in the
public markets currently that is our
best barometer of what the steak is
worth and so the plan is to sell in an
orderly fashion without being highly
disruptive but also trying to move
reasonably quickly over a period of time
to sell those in you know standard
capital market transactions I'm somewhat
limited on what i can say given that
that process has begun their sec rules
governing disclosure but i can say
looking at the blueprint from our other
two very large holdings citigroup we
owned over twenty-five percent and we
monetize that over the course of the
year in a number of different ways and
then general motors as you know we we
owned sixty percent of that and did a
large public offering so I think looking
at the spectrum of our toolkit that is
that is you know how you should look at
what we're going to sell it but again
trying to do it as quickly as
practicable without destroying
value and there's a spectrum of time
within their so we're not going to hold
ourselves to a particular date but you
know we are going to sell as soon as at
least the first you know part of it as
soon as we have the opportunity and
we'll evaluate it from there okay thank
you we have a collection of questions a
couple of questions about executive
compensation and what and they kind of
cut in different directions one of them
notes that executive compensation and
its relationship to risk-taking can be
said to have been overblown by the media
and the American public resulting in
sweeping regulatory changes to align
executive compensation with shareholder
interests do you agree with this or not
and then a further question what would
you like to see in the rules on
executive compensation and that's a
press question okay so first and
foremost a lot of the regulation is
getting discussed right now and in terms
of what things will look like going
forward I think there's general
agreement that incentives need to be
aligned I don't have a particular view
on the overall size of executive
compensation I don't think that's a
major issue it is is how that's
determined and what are the incentives
so I think you know the general premise
of looking out over a longer time
horizon which both allows certainly
reduces the gaming going into sort of
one year time horizons and then having
the ability to claw back as we saw in
the crisis there were paper fake profits
that were based really on fiction and I
think those are areas what you're trying
to solve for again I think there are
lots of ways to do it I think we need to
be very careful not to create another
set of distortions so I think a
broad-based principle of more
compensation in the form of equity more
deferred compensation these are all
steps in the right direction I don't
profess to be an expert on it I think as
far as you know shareholders I think
it's always good for shareholders to
play more active role in the governor
so there of their company I think there
will be you know you'll see more on
say-on-pay votes and I think again
that's that something is more about
corporate governance but shareholders
need to do their part to to essentially
to vote and guide boards as to what they
feel is appropriate but again I think
you know there needs to be balance I
think you don't want a situation where
certain parts of the financial system
have certain regulations other parts
don't particularly since we live in a
global economy there needs to be a lot
of coordination there because then you
just you'll end up having similar forms
of instead of regulatory arbitrage
you'll have compensation arbitrage and I
don't think that's that's beneficial so
I think it needs to be done carefully
needs to be done you know sensibly but
again along the same themes of
longer-term horizons okay thank you and
let me raise two last questions first is
this issue you just mentioned of
regulatory arbitrage and one question
here from a second year student is does
the existence of many regulators and
agency overlaps create the groundwork
the ground for big banks to circumvent
the rules or is that been resolved I
think it's a great question I'd like to
say it's been fully resolved I I don't
know I think time will tell you no
different countries have different
regulatory regimes and so those that
have one centralized regulator still had
similar problems versus of fragmented
system they were different issues there
were different lapses and oversight so
it's not to say one is definitely better
than the other that being said there
needs to clearly be more coordination
and I'm not sure I know the best way to
do that so I think dodd-frank brings in
some of this sort of someone sitting on
top having data to all you know look at
all of them but in the real world and I
think that works very well in theory I
think practically speaking it will be
difficult because institutions that
exist that have long histories have long
personal have literally have
personalities you know tend to do things
their own way and that creates these
separate entities so I think it depends
and we'll see but I don't
it's definitively yes that's been solved
but time will tell one question here is
in light of tarps outcome what do you
see as the future of the GSEs in terms
of government assistance in the size and
scope of measures going forward good
question obviously played a big role in
mortgage finance and I think you know as
you know now particularly now the gses
account for a very substantial portion
of mortgages so thankfully I didn't have
to come up with an answer the
administration just released a white
paper on the future of Housing Finance I
guess I'll just simplify it and it's
still you know going to get debated but
from a spectrum of the government should
do all housing finance to the government
should have no role it's sort of now
we're here okay so I think the
administration has put forth a set of
options which are along this spectrum
and one is a little closer to totally
private market and the other is maybe a
little more activity in certain cases
what are those cases I think again the
purpose originally of the gc's you want
a stable mortgage market I think there
are benefits to in times of stress for
people to continue to be able to get
mortgages so I think you know that's one
area getting looked at which is only
providing they're only as a role for the
government in times of stress and again
it's on this spectrum that that that I
think Congress will need to debate and
will debate going forward but there will
definitely be a diminished role which is
right now the government is the role in
mortgage finance I think as you saw the
most important point the reason why
Fannie and Freddie will ultimately be
wind down I mean done so responsibly
done so with still honoring its
obligations is that you can't have a
system of privatized profits but
socialize losses which is essentially
what occurred so going to be
dramatically changed going to be debated
going forward if you have ideas you know
we'd be happy to listen you and if you
have strong ideas talk to your
Congressman because they're going to
ultimately have to debate but I think
that is something that needs to be done
carefully and it'll probably take a few
years before final legislation comes out
well thank you very much you've been
very generous with your time and we're
very grateful to you I think we we will
have an opportunity for students to
remain after this session for an
informal very off-the-record kind of
just exchange your views but before we
do that please join me in thanking mr.
Miller thank you thanks for coming